he works out are you going to vote for
next year no it's what we would call in
Britain the Hobson's choice oh what's
that mean hey hey hey don't don't insult
my man Donald do not doesn't even matter
which way you go you're gonna get
screwed I mean
careful pierce the last
rapper that I interviewed in this very
Studio was
yay Kanye West yeah uh how is it yay
come on the show yay come on what up
guys welcome to the Jazz pearly things
you YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell the way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started today we're going to
be reacting to Ice Cube on Pierce Morgan
to tell his story of how he turned down
a business deal because it didn't align
with his morals buy ice cube we'll ask
you thank you so much for joining me
thanks for having me great to have you
it's good to be here a Bonafide a legend
oh thank you thank you you let me call a
legend uh it's cool you know uh it's
it's cool it's it's interesting because
I'm still you know here and I'm I still
feel like I got so much to do so um it's
nice you were born O'Shea Jackson who
actually calls you O'Shea uh my mom my
my pops my wife my brothers and sisters
sometimes but mostly everybody call me
cute is is O'Shea different yeah yeah
yeah and what Shay's my real my real
name and when I hear that I I'm either
looking for my family or check you know
I mean like you can call me on say hope
you got a check and um cube is what my
friends been calling me since I was 12
years old
let me ask you this there's been a lot
of stuff about the state of the world
about the state of America where do you
see things right now I think um I think
you know people are very polarized in
all kind of ways people are afraid to
speak out because of the cancer culture
cancel I said cancer cancer culture that
we have today so I just think you know
people are afraid and they're running to
their Corners you know in a way it is a
cancer cancer it behaves like that it
does because it makes not only the
person that's getting canceled uh
they're trying to shut them up but
anybody's watching now they shut up
because they say if it can happen to
this guy it can happen to me so by by
Smashing somebody who says something
that you might not like and canceling
them it actually reverberates throughout
the whole community and everybody now is
watching what they they say all the time
see what's the answer to this because I
think it's crazy that in a democracy
like the United States like the United
Kingdom the people are too frightened to
speak their mind and say what they think
what do we do about this I think you say
what you want to say and to hell with
the consequences you got to be willing
to fight for your rights and fight hell
yeah base based because that's what
they'll try to do they'll try to say
that you can't say what you want to say
because of the backlash and the
consequence and it's just like I'm so
tired of this I'm tired of
people pandering to women I'm tired of
them pandering to make money
that's it or what you believe in and if
you're a person who believes in freedom
of speech you have to fight and say what
you feel and let chips fall where they
may and uh stand on that and you know it
may not be an easy road but
um I think you feel better about
yourself when you say what needs to be
said at the time it needs to be said and
not afterwards where you go home and
think I should have said this when that
guy was there or when I was there I
should have said that and I didn't want
you more you can definitely say what the
hell do you like on this show it's
called it's called uncensored well
that's why I'm here man you know people
we've been our citizen
um let me ask you this it's America more
racist or less racist than when you were
a kid I think it's pretty much the same
because it's uh it's institutionalized
and you know the institution takes on
different faces so to speak uh but you
know I don't know if the if racism in
the financial sector or has gotten any
better
um we still have a hard time getting
Capital when we need it we still have a
hard time
um having that access to those you know
currency streams that's out there
um and and so it affects us in the same
way in 1865 black people own
um maybe one or two percent of America
um and I believe we're still in that
same place is that right yeah it's
barely changed barely has changed in
some ways it's gotten worser I mean
worser but it's gotten worse
um I think the corner commission did
something in 1968 about the poverty
um and you know what's so funny about
this racism talk and how hard it is for
black people to gain power and wealth in
the United States they always make it
seem like it is the problem of
institutionalized racism meanwhile in
the same breath they forget to mention
how black people always refuse to work
with each other like black people in
America literally hate each other they
kill each other they rub each other yes
you might say it's the fault of of
institutionalized racism like from the
beginning but now that you are aware of
that why haven't you guys come together
to work together to build your own
communities why are you still killing
each other why are you still rubbing
each other you see your your fellow
black man on the street walking down the
road on his own at night and then the
first thought that comes here is to Rob
him how is that the fault of
institutionalized racism so like I it's
just funny because at the end of the day
the only way black people are going to
get anything is for them to come
together and work together expecting
another group of people to give you
anything is never going to happen and
how it affects all the people and and
we're we're worse than we were in 1968.
the last rapper that I interviewed in
this very Studio was yay Kanye West yay
uh you've had a wobbly relationship with
him but you're back at your backup are
they beef I don't even know track
already you saw him in fact a few days
ago yeah a couple weeks ago uh
interesting about rappers is they always
make their beef public there are so many
like conservatives that fight behind and
same with the red pill actually it's
really irritating like there's so many
conservatives that fight behind the
scenes that you wouldn't even know like
you would literally have no idea because
they just don't make that public
but I don't know what it is about like
rappers and even in the red pill like
all of the beef they make so public
always cool you know he just he spoke my
name without really explaining what he
meant and that's literally that stems
from a victim mindset like when you when
you think you're a victim you always
want to make things public oh you
actually always feel like you're wrong
because if you think about it really and
truly red pill in itself is good but the
people that majority of the people that
are red pill doing the wrong I don't I
don't know if I'm putting it just
correctly but I think majority of people
that are red pill are going down the
wrong path even after being ready so you
get red peeled and you still have a
victim mentality right that's exactly
what's happened and I just really
couldn't leave that statement out there
without you know he never explained what
he meant and so I had to you know kind
of rebut that but since then we've
talked and I think I think yay
understands that generalizing will will
always get you in in more hot water than
being very specific I think we should
generalize more I think that saying
don't generalize as women policing
language and when you hear that that's a
woman a woman is behind that I don't
know if it's a woman in the media I
don't know if it's his mom his sister
his whatever but like that right there
because Men Behind Closed Doors they
don't talk like this so when you say
don't generalize that's women and the
reason why generalization is being
frowned upon is the same reason like
what we said about
um lost the thoughts but basically the
reason why generalization is yeah about
language so when when you are able to
connections I am able to put people in a
group then that is literally you
building a force against yourself so the
best way to split the power up is to
make sure that things are not
generalized is to make sure that
everything is separated to make sure
that people are diverse right so it's
like the more you want to see the
patterns it's almost like a threat to
the status right right because I haven't
really seen much of it since I
interviewed him he's kind of disappeared
I mean how is it yay come on the show
yay come on how's he dealing with what's
happened to him I believe he's doing
great you know he's still you know
dealing with um with some people trying
to hold on to his money
um but for the most part I believe he's
um in a good space you know learned a
lot from this past year and you know
hopefully he'll come out better on the
other side when you saw some of the
crazier things he was saying the
anti-semitic statements he was making
what did you feel at some someone who
knew him well what did you feel about
that I felt that um if he was really
upset with specific people that that the
the message he was saying would uh would
kind of hijack what he's really
um
upset about you know and um and you know
that's that's kind of what happened
um you just can't generalize you have to
be specific especially if you're
um talking about uh anybody any race of
people you have to be specific on who
exactly you're talking about why are
people able to generalize about white
men and nobody bats an eye like that's
so common rich white men have all the
Power white men white men like why why
are we able to generalize about white
men but any other group then it's bad
even if I say like this is how white
women move there's like a reaction you
know what I'm saying like but when it's
white men nobody cares like I hear that
all the time talk about the music
industry huge amount of attention been
given to artificial intelligence now
yeah uh clearly it has awesome power not
least to replicate how people like you
would make music what do you feel about
that I think it's terrible I think it's
uh it's gonna make people lazier less
creative you know could you imagine if
an actor like if I decide not to do a
sequel the movie company said we have we
have the rights to your likeness right
we're going to put you in this sequel
whether you want to be or not because we
have the right to and how to use AI to
put ice cube in a movie I don't want to
be in saying things I don't want to say
and doing things I wouldn't do so to me
that's terrible or or taking an artist
that's passed away and having them do a
new song with lyrics that they may not
agree with
um it's just you know we're just it's a
slippery slope that it will hurt us more
than it will help us is there a benefit
that you can see well you could use AI
to enhance what you do I mean we use you
know automation here and there to help
advance and make ours us sound better
you know once you take the paintbrush
out of the painter's hand is it really a
painting from him you know right well
it's an interesting question isn't it is
it I mean I don't know like if I if
somebody does a ice cube AI song how
could it be an Ice Cube song it's an
artificial it's like a mannequin or a
puppet or you know that's how I look at
it it's not real do you think it's going
to kill us all artificial intelligence
um
Professor Stephen Hawking before he died
and I said what's the biggest threat to
mankind he said we're not official
intelligence learns to self-design yeah
I think you know there are it's already
figuring us out in a lot of different
ways I've heard that it's learned how to
lie yeah
um you know this AI learns how to lie
now this is the you know in every
science science fiction movie this is
the beginning of the end yes yeah
definitely if you knew it was about to
end what would you what would you do on
your last day
um you've got 24 hours to live hug my
family love them explain to them how
much I care about them
um pray to my maker and prepare myself
but you have a lost meal probably so
yeah but yeah everything I could stuff
a little bit of worry about I think
right yeah yeah you know I'll be
probably sick off everything on that day
you turned down a nine million dollar
movie role in 2020. nine million dollar
movie rule he turned down one because
that's what I was waiting for uh the
kovid vaccine is being mandated in
Hollywood at the time any regrets
there's a lot of money not at all and I
won't regret you know my thought when I
heard that story you must be even richer
than I think you are
I mean everybody can use nine million
dollars I don't care how rich they think
they are you know everybody can use that
money I could have used that money my
family could use that money but I felt
like you know your health is worth more
than all the money in the world because
if you had all the money in the world
and you wasn't healthy you would you
would use that money to get healthy so
to me it was an experimental drug and um
they had no time to and it was so crazy
like when all this was going on I
remember a certain friends I made a
certain video about me later was saying
that like when she had kids we couldn't
see them they weren't vaccinated and
like they were saying she was saying it
was perfectly okay perfectly okay
um for perf like you had to be
vaccinated to go to her to her wedding
and this is the problem like we're so
women are so easy to propagate because
we'll see some scary story and start
freaking out and then start saying this
this and this needs to happen and the
men are supposed to say it darling it'll
be fine stop you know that you don't
need to do all this but this is the
problem female-led households see the
long-term effects like most not
vaccinated I've been vaccinated when I
was a kid but these are drugs that have
been tested for decades and you know
pretty much most of the side effects I
mean ultimately I felt about covert
vaccines that once it was established
against what they initially thought that
you could still transmit the virus yeah
Pierce had to walk back he was
pro-vaccine he had to walk back that one
yes he did you were vaccinated or not to
me it becomes a personal choice then
it's down to you yeah without a doubt
and you know the pharmaceutical
companies made a lot of money businesses
close you know it was it's like an
incentive even when things are not going
right to keep going
um kind of like the war machine you know
if you make the bullets and the
Band-Aids you're gonna always want to be
in war because it's profitable have you
watched out are you going to vote for
next year no it's what we would call in
Britain the Hobson's choice
hell what's that mean hey hey hey don't
don't insult my man Donald do not
doesn't matter you matter which way you
go you're gonna get screwed I mean
careful pierce the bite looks like I'm
not a political person that much but I
gotta Donald Trump is goaded I don't
care what anyone says the Manny's goated
there it is Donald Trump might be in a
prison cell so if that's the choice what
does it say oh because the Liberals will
just lock them up for nothing for
nothing America you know America needs
to re-examine where we are where we're
going who we want to lead us and what
kind of country we actually want to be
you know um a lot of choices I've become
independent in all this because I like
to sit back and see you know who's
really gonna be the best choice
unfortunately the choices are not
um always top-notch so have you thought
of running yourself oh I would never run
it might be a vacancy now can you nah
I don't want to be a politician you know
they can King
well actually I've always felt if it
hadn't been for King George III being so
useless you could still have the moniker
here and it could be king Pierce I mean
right I could share the throne with you
yeah pink peers and King Cube hey uh I
think it's only room for one king man
it's crazy 9
million dollars nine million
I have the longest arms on YouTube
um wow and that's the thing like during
covet it was so crazy how passionate
people got and I really do respect the
people that did not get vaccinated
whether or not they're offered money
whether or not their job told them to
their country told them to they stood
strong and did not get vaxxed but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next time